kanye west assured fans he's taking
accountability for his actions following
some controversial posts about his ex
kim kardashian
here's the latest on tuesday the rapper
took to instagram to make amends just do
something for my heart kanye shared a
stylized photo of himself writing quote
i've learned that using all caps makes
people feel like i'm screaming at them
i'm working on my communication
adding quote thank you everybody for
supporting me among kanye's recent post
were screenshots of a text message
conversation allegedly with kim
it's a different experience for sure he
now says quote i know sharing
screenshots was jarring and came off as
harassing kim i take accountability i'm
still learning in real time i don't have
all the answers to be a good leader is
to be a good listener in one of the many
now deleted posts from monday kim
allegedly expressed concern for
boyfriend pete davidson following
kanye's repeated comments about their
relationship you just gotta roll with it
the first message read quote you are
creating a dangerous and scary
environment and someone will hurt pete
and this will be all your fault kanye
wrote alongside the snapshot quote upon
my wife's request please nobody do
anything physical to skeet i'm going to
handle the situation myself in another
post kim further explained her concerns
allegedly writing quote there are
dangerous people out there and this is
scary and it doesn't have to be
seemingly in response to kanye sharing
screenshots of their messages kim later
allegedly asked quote why can't you keep
any of our conversations private kanye
kicked off monday's social media
marathon with these photos the images
seemingly show a truckload of flowers
kanye delivered to kim's house and it
should be noted this followed kim and
pete's night out in the big apple it was
calming on sunday the couple shared a
date night in new york city they were
spotted sharing a kiss and holding hands
kanye how are you
how are you doing today oh what up baby
how you been
good you with the babies today
enjoy enjoy on the west coast kanye was
attending super bowl 56 stepping out
with his eldest kids north and saint
you know we got good seats dorothy
safety is
kanye donned an all-black look while
eight-year-old north and six-year-old
saints sported football jerseys for the
big game and that glove right there that
was given to yay by l.a rams player
odell beckham jr who tossed him up here
before taking to the field
[Applause]
meanwhile jonathan chebin one of kim's
besties recently voiced to et his
support for the new relationship as one
of kim's closest confidants what do you
think of her and pete together um i
think it's cool you know what she's
having fun i guess you know uh you know
i i've hung out with them a couple of
times and you know i love her to death
so whatever whatever makes her happy ask
her friend how are you supporting her
through all the kind of kanye craziness
that's happening i don't even know
anything about that so i love kanye too
man he's a genius excuse me
but you know listen i just i hope i hope
everybody
ends up settling